welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldier is now complete
leaving fans wanting more more of the
great stuff in this series like sam's
relationship with bucky isaiah bradley
and zemo i'm talking hours two three and
four of that dancing
but also more answers about the intent
behind this series it's flag smashers
subplot and some peculiar loose ends
like the
vaccines and the weird killing off of a
name actress without giving her a single
line of dialogue which i have speculated
to be a deleted storyline on this show
well we did just get some thought
provoking confirmations from series
creator malcolm spellman
the talent behind everything you loved
on this series and now tasked with
writing the fourth captain america movie
following sam wilson and according to
spelman
yes there was a deleted storyline from
this show though
he seems reluctant to say how connected
it was to the pandemic either way i'm
gonna break down what we know about this
deleted plot but first some background
so halfway through this series i began
to pick up in my episode breakdown some
editing inconsistencies like a larger
than usual reliance on dub dialogue with
the flag smasher scenes
compared to the scenes where it was
clear they just shot what was initially
scripted i mean it's hard to know for
sure because movies and tv shows use
adr all the time pretty much any time
there's an over the shoulder shot
the character facing away from us is
moving their draw or gesturing in a way
that doesn't perfectly match the cut
but there is some glaring evidence that
something big
in this series was changed clear
glitches in the matrix folks the actress
veronica falcone was cast as the flag
smasher matriarch mamadonia madani
and despite falcone's known reputation
from roles in perry mason
and the upcoming jungle cruise film with
the rock her character was just weirdly
killed off and left with no dialogue
whatsoever
and then i pointed out how her cause of
death is just kind of brushed off as
tuberculosis
in an exposition dump line from dr nagle
that was clearly dubbed in later via adr
but a couple of days ago she called and
asked if i could help someone
named donya madani poor woman has
tuberculosis
typical of overpopulation and
displacement camps like that
additionally episode 2 shows bucky
discovering that the flagsmashers were
stealing vaccines
clearly labeled on those large shipping
crates and then they were never brought
up again
on top of other weird stuff like sharon
in episode 4 having unexplained cuts on
her lip and knuckles
despite those wounds not appearing in an
earlier scene in that day
a scene where much of her dialogue does
not match her lip movement
you killed the golden goose magic poor
is about to get real nasty
and now that we know that sharon is the
power broker it's not likely she would
have been beaten up after that
so my theory was that there might have
been some subplot
related to the pandemic or some
bioweapon that someone at the studio
worried might look too similar to covet
19
and it was changed to avoid the
appearance of a suggestion that a
global virus might have been engineered
from an asian country even
a fictional asian country like magipore
but again none of that has been
confirmed but then
after the finale malcolm spelman was
asked about this
by amon warman on the fade to black
podcast there's been a lot of talk
over the last few weeks about a lost
storyline due to the pandemic
if so what was that storyline and how
much rejigging did you guys have to do
i've been told to stop saying that
i loved it you know what i'm saying it
had nothing to do with the pandemic i
want to see if we can get some of the
writers and do a book run
on it no i i think kevin duggan but i
i've been told to stop talking about
that
interesting so spellman confirms that
there was
some deleted storyline and yes he does
say here that it had nothing to do with
pandemic
but he also cryptically says i've been
told to stop
saying that and he repeats i've been
told to stop talking about that
almost as if he had been telling people
that there was some deleted pandemic
storyline maybe in jest maybe in truth
and someone at disney told him to keep a
lid on that the deleted storyline might
have had less to do with covid19 than
it's been made out to
the vaccines could have just been for
the general health of the refugees the
flag smashers were trying to help but
no one can deny that something happened
with veronica falcone's character here
and spelman teases that whatever this
storyline was
it was something that he loved and he
wants to see written out it's almost
like he's defending it and he even
further confirmed with deadline that the
part of his vision
that he wants to see written out as a
book in this mystery storyline
is this mystery storyline that had to be
deleted that he can't talk about but
before we continue thanks to display for
sponsoring this video
just blate makes high quality art prints
on metal they have lots of great artist
designs from the worlds of gaming
anime and comics including a new
exclusive collection
of officially licensed falcon and winter
soldier posters
check out some of my favorite displays
using the link in the description you'll
also get a sweet discount
so they mount on your wall with a magnet
no tools needed no holes in the wall
with display you can build collections
of the things you're passionate about
right on your wall
with every display that you buy you
plant one tree through displaced
partnership with the non-profit trees
for the future
check out some of my favorite marvel dc
and star wars displays and get your own
using the link in the description and
get a special discount you'll be
supporting our channel and making some
major upgrades to your walls so click
that
link and get your own displate now it's
clear that donya died from some kind of
illness but i
highly doubt it was tb but it might have
been also very unlike covet 19 but
someone at the studio just worried it
might remind people too much of it
anyway
but while we're speculating on what this
deleted storyline was we have to assume
that donia and carly's relationship was
designed to connect to the rest of the
show
like if you look at the deeper themes
that spelman wanted to address in the
series
look to isaiah bradley an elderly test
subject of super soldier serum
a person of color cruelly experimented
on by his government
and then incarcerated forgotten erased
interesting how
in this same podcast interview spelman
hints that there was
more to that super soldier serum history
with isaiah
and hydra before dr nagle that they were
not able to get to
i know the founding principle was we had
to limit the scope like we felt like
hydra
infiltrated whatever program had isaiah
was not a hydra program hydra
infiltrated and got it and we felt like
the uh the knowledge of who knew and who
didn't for the logic to work
had to be contained because once too
many people know
then the people who would get them out
would have known and then also how did
that nurse declare him dead
um so i can't remember how deep the into
shield that got
we went into the history on the uh when
zemo had the book
on the women's program and him knowing
like the list of scientists who have
built the serum
there was even a dude i don't know i'm
sorry
yeah that other serum scientist dude
before spelman cuts himself off
who was that and who did he experiment
on could
dania madani have been a parallel figure
to isaiah bradley
as the matriarch of a militant group
could she have had
a past connected to the super soldier
history with
similar experimentation scarring her
with a weakened immune system
especially vulnerable when the world's
population doubles and allows diseases
to spread more rapidly
but unfortunately not have access to a
vaccine
carly's departure from the power broker
sharon carter was kind of left a mystery
something vaguely talked about but not
shown maybe carly was a soldier for hire
for sharon
the way sam was a contractor for the us
government and the way isaiah bradley
opened sam's eyes to the truth of the
super soldier serum could be the way
carly's eyes were opened by dania madani
leading to carly adopting the philosophy
of madani's flag smashers organization
making sam and carly parallel figures
explaining why
and sam connected on the level they did
why carly felt so betrayed when sam
shows up wearing those colors
giving greater weight to why sam refused
to fight back why he cradled her like an
angel delivering her to the afterlife it
is clear spellman intended the falcon of
the winter soldier to be a story about
soldiers struggling over whether to
fight for leaders who just view them as
expendable and
whether enhancing their combat skills
would play into the inhumanity of that
authority and i think it's possible for
carly's real storyline to be meant to be
part of that message
but what do you think this deleted
storyline was support this channel by
checking out our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerge.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at davos follow me
rockstars and subscribe to new rockstars
for breakdowns of everything marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you